[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview and
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now the Observer describes the
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi as a fighting for his political
life after his admission of what he
called a careless mistake in settling
his tax affairs
the Sunday Times leads with a report
from the trenches in Ukraine but also
features claims that Boris Johnson had
help from Richard Sharp in arranging
alone just weeks before Mr Sharp was
appointed chair of the BBC Mr Johnson
has described the reports as rubbish and
Mr Sharp has insisted there is no
conflict with his position
the Sunday people says that one of the
victims of rapist Metropolitan policeman
David Carrick is to sue the force for
damages
the Sunday Express has details of the
king's coronation which it's understood
he wants to be a unifying National
occasion
the Sunday Telegraph says refugees NHS
staff and the lgbtq plus Community will
all have their voices reflected in the
celebrations
and staying with matters Royal The
Mirror Has news of what it describes as
a new lie discovered in Prince Harry's
Memoir spare
the sun claims Prince Andrew's lawyers
will attempt to overturn the financial
settlement reached with his accuser
Virginia du Frey he has always denied
any wrongdoing
and the star tells us that younger
Generations are shunning sweet snacks
Like Biscuits instead opting for Savory
Foods like samosas
hmm a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Christina Patterson and Jake Wallace
Simons welcome to both of you let's
start with the Observer and uh there's
the story about Nadine zahawi's tax
Affairs he has described it as a
carelessness and
the headline really describing the
situation in terms of him fighting for
his political life Christina do you
think that's that is the case
so we've all done it haven't we sort of
wanted to look at our tax return and
suddenly realize we have to pay 4.8
million so you know I have full sympathy
for him in his tiny little error
um I also don't find it terribly
convincing that it is a tiny little
error so uh yes he does seem to be
fighting for his political life tonight
and it seems literally breathtaking that
this man could have been in charge of
the treasury he was Chancellor of the
exchequer at the time when all of this
was being discussed and we don't know
exactly when the bill was settled
because it seems that he was very
evasive about his tax Affairs for quite
a while and that he had had lawyers send
threats or what seemed like threats to
people who were investigating them so
I'm afraid this does look extremely
fishy and uh it seems to me like another
death and nail in the coffin for this
government which really has a very last
gaze feeling at the moment so yes I
imagine Nadim zahawi at the moment is
really feeling pretty worried for his
future and the Tory party can't be
delighted either that it's actual
chairman
um seems to have massively
underestimated how much tax he has to
pay
but Jake he does say that the tax
Authority concluded that he'd made a
careless but not deliberate error and he
chose to settle the matter and pay what
they said was due which was the right
thing to do
um does that not draw a line under the
whole Affair he has put out a statement
and explained what what has gone on
well he has paid the penalty which we
think is about 1.1 million
um and as we surprised we understand it
no further action has been taken by the
hmrc
um so in a way you know justice has been
done he's paid his penalties paid his
Jews
um and uh he has denied certain elements
of the speculation and charges against
him including that he had some offshore
involvement but it's very very
complicated this case uh his statement
raised in many ways more questions than
it answered it mentioned some some
founding shares in his company
ugav that were owned by his father 22
years ago it was not quite clear how
that came into it
um I mean overall I think he'll feel
um that he did the right thing and that
he should be seen to be Vindicated but
unfortunately uh in the eyes of the
public that the very best way in which
this comes across is that he made an
error which led him to have to pay 1.1
million pounds which only highlights The
Fabulous wealth at the top of the Tory
party both him and as we know Richard
sunac and given the ripeness of the
politics of envy and how people tend to
feel I mean the cost of living crisis
these days quite rightly in some cases
in many cases uh people are not going to
like that very much at all even in the
best case scenario yeah the papers are
pointing to the fact that you know the
the admission does raise questions for
the Prime Minister Rashid sunak over
what he knew about the settlement and
when Christina
absolutely and it seems I mean really
unimaginable actually that we could have
somebody in charge of the finances of
this country who as Jake says is so
super wealthy that he can happily pay a
1.1 million penalty and the word penalty
does imply that there has been
wrongdoing and okay he says it you know
was a little mistake but did he really
not think that there was any tax due on
this uh account and as has been raised
by a number of people it seems that a
substantial number of founding shares of
yougoth were given to his father and his
father's role in the business and
building of ugav isn't clear at all so
it looks as if Nadine zahari has
benefited from an offshore tax
investment which looks as if it was set
up to avoid tax paying tax and if you
have someone you know combined with
Rishi sunak who as we know his wife was
an Dom until recently it looks as if the
people who run this country who spend
our taxes are extremely reluctant to pay
any tax so I I don't know I can't
imagine that Richie soon I didn't know
about this because this has been an
under investigation for some time and
you don't appoint someone as chairman of
the Tory party without doing a little
bit of due diligence so it seems to me
that there is it looks like complicity
at the top and it looks like
um tax avoidance is a perfectly
acceptable thing for the Tory party
um until until you're found out and you
know that's really not a good look and
as Jake says it's actually very
distressing for people when they are
really really struggling to pay their
bills to see people who are so super
wealthy that a few million here and
there really makes little difference to
them
um Jake what what do you make of the
excuse from Nadeem sahabi that he was
simply careless um what do you think the
public will make of that
well I think um as I said you know
people are going through a cost of
living crisis and they they won't
appreciate having this level of fabulous
wealth uh thrust into their faces via
the headlines but at the same time I
think the people understand that there's
nothing wrong with being rich uh it's
something that all of us would like to
be uh and uh Nadim zahawi in particular
you know he worked his way up
um you know from the bottom and worked
very very hard and started ugav which is
a fabulously successful company and I'm
sure deserves uh all the all the um
winnings that he's managed to to get
um but I think that nonetheless having
this level of wealth placed front and
center in people's minds just it
encourages the sense that uh the top of
the Tory party is out of touch and
that's not a a look that anybody in
government would like to Foster
particularly with the next election
almost around the corner really next
year and they want to appear like
they're they're feeling the people
suffering through the cost living crisis
and unfortunately stories like this
really dispel that notion let's stay
with Westminster and move to the times
Christina and this story concerning a
previous prime minister Boris Johnson
and a sum of money 800 000 pounds to be
precise and alone that he was um uh
profit really helped to arrange Alone by
the BBC boss takes us into the detail of
of this story this also is fairly
complex well this is quite an
extraordinary story the
um allegation is that Richard Sharp
who's the chairman of the BBC actually
helped to arrange the 800 000 loan that
emerged in the last week that front by
um a rather distant cousin of Boris
Johnson's because Boris Johnson clearly
couldn't possibly live on the 140 Grand
that you get or whatever it is that you
get as prime minister and obviously had
to have access to other funds to
um fund his many children and his rather
expensive lifestyle so that was a pretty
shocking Revelation in itself but the
fact that according to this story
Richard Sharp was the person he was
asked by
um Boris Johnson's cousin to set up the
discussions with Boris Johnson and there
was a dinner apparently and um and
apparently Richard Sharp talked to Simon
case the cabinet secretary and um and it
seems that Richard Sharp applied to bbbc
Chairman and according to this story at
no point mentioned that he was had been
involved in helping to set up this loan
he was also by the way a good friend
apparently or Boris Johnson's they went
skiing together so it certainly looks
like cronyism and I I understand that
Richard Sharp has denied any involvement
and Boris Johnson has as he generally
does claimed the story is rubbish or a
pyramid of people or whatever word he
has chosen on this particular occasion
but from the story as reported here it
doesn't seem to reflect very well on
anyone actually and it is alarming if
somebody is running the BBC who actually
arranged finance that was Undeclared for
the prime minister
yes and uh we know that the SMP in labor
are calling for investigations uh into
this case Jake don't we
that's right they are and uh when we
expect that from opposition parties I
mean I think it's important to point out
right at the start of this that both
Boris Johnson and Richard Sharp deny any
wrongdoing at all Richard Sharp denies
uh arranging this 800 000 pound loan
which was required by uh Boris Johnson
when he was hard up there were quite a
few stories around at the time about him
struggling to live on his prime minister
Prime ministerial salary on account of
his expensive divorce and his child
maintenance payments and doing up
Downing streets and all the rest of it
um so there are very strong denials
coming from both of these men involved
and certainly nothing has been has been
conclusively proven
um but it just this story just connects
with the story we spoke about just now
about Nadeem zahawi uh is is not a good
uh day for the Tories for the for the
cabinet with these sorts of stories
floating about which just have the wrong
kind of whiff about them and seem to
play into people's preconceptions uh
certainly on the left of what uh of
Tory's sleeves and all the rest of it
which has been around for for decades
but you know it may very well be that
neither of these men did anything wrong
at all
um and it all just could be you know
negative headlines
um uh unfairly pinned upon them but only
time will tell and if there is that
investigation uh then we'll certainly uh
see the conclusions for ourselves no
indeed well labor has reported uh the
former prime minister to the parliament
standards Watchdog
um but just to reiterate what what uh
all sides are saying Richard Sharp he's
been quoted as saying there is not a
conflict when I Simply Connected at his
request Mr Blythe he's referring to
sambly that's the multi-millionaire
Canadian businessman and incidentally a
distant cousin of Boris Johnson uh
connected him with the cabinet secretary
and had no further involvement
whatsoever and a spokesman for Boris
Johnson has said this is rubbish Richard
Sharp has never given any Financial
advice to Boris Johnson nor has Mr
Johnson sought any Financial advice from
him there has never been any
remuneration or compensation to Mr charp
from Boris Johnson for this or any other
service Mr Johnson did indeed have
dinner with the Mr Sharp whom he was
known for almost 20 years and with his
cousin so what big deal all Mr Johnson's
Financial Arrangements have been
properly declared and registered on the
advice of officials uh thank you both
for the moment we are going to take a
break
and uh just to say we're getting a first
look at plans for the king's coronation
in May more on that when we come back
[Music]
thank you
you're watching the Press preview still
with me Christina Patterson and Jake
Wallace Simons or they will be in any
second there you are let's have a look
at the express story regarding the
king's coronation we've got some further
details released Christina
yes and apparently uh King Charles wants
this to be a joyful occasion well he
would hardly want it to be a miserable
occasion but I particularly imagine that
after everything that one of his sons
has been doing recently he's
particularly Keen to make it a very
joyful occasion and to bury some of the
misery that that has caused but um he's
talked about uh wanting it to be a kind
of celebration of Multicultural Britain
of refugees of the NHS which suggests to
me that there is a desire to perhaps
emphasize some aspects of British life
which the Tories have been Keen rather
less Keen to emphasize in the last few
years and that I think was also evident
in his Christmas speech which um was
very moving but you know made it clear
that he has a Compassionate Heart and
does care about people who um perhaps
the government seems to care slightly
less for at the moment so I hope it will
be a joyful occasion we could certainly
do with some cheering up and um I hope I
hope it's a great success and I hope
that King Charles himself feels it's a
great success because uh he's following
in some difficult footsteps his mother
was a really wonderful Monarch whether
whether or not you support the monarchy
I think she was she did the job
magnificently and she's a she's a tough
job to follow
um
there are all sources saying that the
coronation needs to be Majestic but
inclusive to reflect a diverse modern
Britain that's a certainly the theme
that keeps coming through Jake
that's right there's going to be two
main parts to the coronation the first
one is going to be on Saturday May the
6th that's going to be the big Pomp and
Circumstance event with uh 3 000 people
it's going to take two hours it's going
to be at Westminster Abbey and
interestingly
um uh Queen Camilla is going to be
crowned alongside uh King Charles which
is a break from precedent uh it's a very
interesting Innovation which he's
introducing as well as he's the fact
he's going to be wearing a military
uniform rather than the traditional
garters that were worn by his
grandfather great grandfather and going
back into the Mists of times that's
going to be the big Pomp and
Circumstance event and then the next day
on the seventh there's going to be a big
party at Windsor Castle and that's going
to involve not just uh Headliners but
also members of the public you know
Community choirs uh singing together it
does seem like it will be a big a knees
up we are running out of time Jake uh
but just to say it's understood that the
Monarch is Keen for his younger son
Harry to attend also